foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for being with us America we're so glad
you're here Rachel Cruz of Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author and a co-host of the smart money
Happy Hour podcast on the Ramsey
networks with our own George camel is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five starting this hour is
Tamara in Little Rock Arkansas hey
Tamara how are you
hi I'm doing well thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so we are a military family and we don't
plan on buying a house until my husband
retires from the military in about 10
years being such a long-term goal how
much should we be setting aside now each
month for a house wow well thanks for
your service we appreciate that you're
welcome yeah do you guys know we're in
10 years where you think you want to end
up
we don't at this point okay
uh where are you guys at on the baby
steps do you guys have Consumer Debt
nope we're in baby six four through six
at this point okay that's awesome
excellent I mean yeah I mean honestly I
mean it's it's a a decade away so I'm
like what the housing Market's gonna be
like where you guys want to end up I
mean there's a lot still in the air so I
mean I would just
you know have a goal of setting maybe a
percentage of my income aside
um every month so more of a percentage
than a dollar amount so that you guys
can still enjoy life I mean y'all are on
baby steps four through six so it's um
you want to be able to you know not
stress about it too much but obviously
plan which I think is really wise so
yeah I would find the percentage of your
income that you know you could you could
set aside and kind of start working and
then as you guys get closer like in five
years
maybe some options kind of start to
shrink of wear and you can kind of look
right because I mean if you're going to
be buying and
Silicon Valley versus Des Moines I mean
those are very you know right to very
separate price points so as you guys
kind of narrow down hey here's where we
want to end up that probably will help
navigate how much more to save the
closer you get to that goal what's your
household income
um we're about 70 000 a year okay and
you have uh are you using military
housing or are you renting correct yes
we live on base so we use our basic
allowance for housing to cover that okay
well you know if you just kind of start
laying out some goals and said hey we
want two hundred thousand dollars
then that'd be 20 000 a year right
correct and uh that'd be pretty cool
you know or or if we want a hundred
thousand dollars it'd be ten thousand
dollars a year whatever it is just start
saying let's start aiming at a goal I I
always think what ends up happening is
your life tends to end your numbers in
your budget uh within reason to tend to
uh mold themselves around whatever your
goal is not having a goal and just
having a general idea oh we ought to be
saving for house uh I I would put down a
particular number and then that gives
you something to form your budget around
and aim at and I don't even care what
the number is I just think there needs
to be a number does that make sense
right
so I mean 200 sounds fun
um that might be a little stressful on
70. uh but uh I didn't set up a
brokerage account
um
we have about 19 000 in at this point
um that's an over and above your
emergency fund
correct yes we have twenty thousand oh
God then you only need 18 000 a year to
get to 200.
yeah and we also
I know where that you can kind of plan
to save up
um like a rent payment
um if your goal is more of a long-term
goal exactly so we're trying to get to
that point you know it's saving up let's
say 1500 or even 2000 but at this point
it just seems too tight for us to be
able to do that 1500 would be 18 000 a
year that that would get you plus the 19
that you've got that would get you to
200. but we're making this number up
it's not a we could have said 300 or we
could have said you know whatever we
said so the point being just give if I
were you guys I would I would say okay
this is my target that's what I'm aiming
at uh because if you aim at nothing
you'll hit it every time and so you want
to aim at something very specific
um and even if you don't make it all the
way at least you know you've got a game
plan and you're moving in the right
direction uh but when it's when it's has
nothing tied to it then that would mess
you up I don't want to do that Jessica's
in Houston hi Jessica welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um my hoping you can help us settle a
disagreement
um my husband and I are on baby step two
um we're getting about five thousand
dollars back from our taxes we are both
self-employed
um I would like to take that money and
just throw it at our debt however my
husband would like to take that money
and purchase a vehicle for his business
he does he's a transportation company
um
his his his
reason for wanting to buy the vehicle is
it would help him bring in more income
to throw at our debt I'm just a little
more hesitant he's gonna buy a five
thousand dollars he's got about five
thousand dollar car
did you suspended on the car did you say
he's gonna buy a five thousand dollar
car is that what you're telling me
um he well it would be a 22 passenger
van as what he's looking at buying for
five thousand dollars
yes
can you get that
for five thousand dollars
um possibly no he's wanting to go into
debt to buy a 22 passenger van and five
thousand dollars is the down payment
you're not telling me he can find a 22
passenger van for 5K I ain't riding in
that
thank you
how much how much did you guys have left
Jessica
um we have
a credit card alone and then two
vehicles one is my vehicle and then one
is his business vehicle how how much
does that all total do you know um it's
about
sixty thousand okay and your household
income is what
it varies because we're both
self-employed so I would say between
um 60 to 80 000.
and how I'm bored is he with paying off
this 60 Grand in debt is he pumped is he
excited
um
a little bit I'm more I think I'm more
wanting to attack the debt and get that
yeah totally bored for sure the proper
answer or the proper way to set the call
up is I am on baby step two and I'm
dragging my husband with me
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's the disagreement so the
disagreement is not really over the 22
passenger van or the five thousand
dollars the disagreement really is over
you guys are not on the same page
he's just going along with you he's not
he's not engaged yeah he's not he's not
an active participant in this goal that
goal that you
have of getting out of debt right if
y'all were both on the same team
attacking the exact same thing then this
would be a really easy answer of course
it's five thousand dollars towards the
debt because that's the answer but I
would really work Jessica and you guys
you guys Focus again on hey what's our
goal in our marriage like what are we
doing as a team that's more of the
discussion you guys need to be having
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their one
action guarantee and Schwing is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
forty percent off selected products
visit blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Cruz Ramsey personality my daughter is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ashley is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Ashley how are you
hey Dave oh my gosh I'm so excited to
talk to you guys you too what's up kiddo
um so my husband and I are looking into
maybe starting a new business we are
totally debt free with a paid four house
we have one year of emergency funds
saved up wow nice
um yes we've been following you and
doing you for seven years since we got
married and so we just got debt free not
too long ago and paid our house off
about a month ago oh wow congratulations
Ashley way to go thank you
um so we are I love food I love making
food people really seem to like respond
well when I post things on Facebook
sharing things and they have actually
come to us wanting us to maybe start a
food truck or like a cafe of some kind
um we talked to our CPA and he was
leaning more towards a food truck
um he said they're like the overhead was
less they were less likely to
um like not go under because of all the
overhead but my concern with the food
truck we had been looking into then is
uh of course you know it would still be
considered depreciating asset correct
like
even if we paid cash and saved up for it
it's still depreciating versus
like a brick and mortar and I guess if
we're owning
if we don't own it we're still paying
rent so I just didn't know if you were
leaned one way or the other I would not
decide my business model based on either
one of those things or based on a CPA's
advice
okay you need to decide your business
model on what you want your dream is
what do you want to operate do you want
to operate a food truck do you want to
operate a brick and mortar and then
let's figure out how to pay for it and
how to make the money to how to make it
profitable
and is there another is there another in
between step like uh start catering
as a start and start to build up your
customer base from catering I know
several excellent chefs that have big
operations now that started as catering
what's your end goal Ashley do you want
to be a a restaurant owner yeah like do
you want to like have like is there a
big dream or is it more just a passion
of yours and you love it and it's
something to do on the side that's
really fun
I've always wanted to be more of a chef
like the food in part of it is more like
my dream and passion my husband was in
the food industry for a while and he
actually was the business side of it so
as far as that I think the the brick and
mortar having like a small Cafe I'm
thinking something kind of small scale
of like the Cracker Barrel I'd love to
have like a little store inside and be
able to combine healthy like Whole Foods
plant-based foods with more like regular
Foods
um like a like a blend of the two so
people that my husband eats Burgers and
Fries and stuff I think the only reason
you're considering a food truck is uh
it's not doesn't sound congruent with
this dream
gotcha the cafe sounds congruent with a
dream
it does yes now that you're talked me
through that it does yeah yeah it just
feels like it the way you say it out
loud and here's the thing
um your your CPA is right about one
thing uh restaurants have a higher
failure rate than almost any other
business category
yeah and uh so you've got to really lean
in on the business operations part not
just the food quality
okay if you make the best and healthiest
food on the planet and no one is there
this isn't going to work
right and so there's the marketing and
the operations of this and what I would
do is I probably would start as a
catering operation
and build a customer base and then look
for a a place to lease
don't buy a piece of real estate and uh
Build You Up build you out a little
restaurant and your leasehold
improvements that you put in there will
be a depreciating asset too but let me I
mean but Ashley like I mean and tell me
if I'm wrong I mean but this could be
hundreds of thousands of dollars I mean
this isn't just like a little thing and
I wonder if that's why the CPA was like
yeah food truck gives me way less
expensive to get something going
not necessarily I mean if you found a
location that the building was there and
someone else had had something in the
kitchen
commercial kitchen items are in there
you go in and renovate you might spend
less than a food truck to renovate it
it's possible and you know to upgrade it
get the Fresh coat of paint and uh you
know uh
that'll work uh you could uh start with
a food truck if you want to but I just
the question is just what you want to do
for the next five years of your life and
I think you want to cook and I think he
wants to run a restaurant and that
doesn't sound like a food truck to me
yeah
um that's a different gig it's a
different feel and even Ashley like
You Know It uh we've been to a few
places uh over the last probably two or
three years people's homes for events
and they have someone come in and cook
and the you know in the and the chef guy
brings his card around he's like next
time you guys have a party I can do I
can do a dinner for eight of your
friends or like you know whatever it is
and I'm like if you get the right people
in a room that taste your food that then
spread the word right like there's ways
to do it so the catering if that's what
you were meaning but even we were coming
in and cooking for for friends and and
having them bring friends and you know I
mean you can start small just to get the
word out uh about what you're doing
because it sounds great but also I just
know restaurant
it's just a big investment like when you
hear when you hear brick and mortar I
mean it's just you're gonna be having
staff you're gonna if there's not
already a kitchen how much those
appliances cost I mean it's just it's a
lot it's a lot um not that it can't be
done actually but it is it is a it's a
feat to take on so it's you guys really
great 100 000 in a truck and you can
drop a hundred thousand dollars into
your leasehold improvements either one
yeah real quickly make sure you've got
the cash and that way then the only
overhead you've got is your lease and
your payroll and your food I just know
there's like the girl I mean I just can
think of probably three or four food
trucks and I don't that started as food
trucks that ended up becoming
restaurants because their brand was so
big here in Nashville that they opened
up a restaurant because of that so I'm
just wondering is that is that a that's
not a stair stepping it can be but then
you got you've still got you either
continue to operate both or you've got
this extra truck left over yeah yeah so
yeah I I just I the question is what she
wants to do I mean I'm with you on the
idea of starting some chefing and Home
Stuff um we were at a high-end uh
charity event your mom and I the other
day and um the food was incredible she
collects the chef's card and um he's
helping us with the family reunion
that's coming up so I mean you know
that's so that's how that's how you get
the business out and so it's it's but
you can build a clientele based on that
and then if like we have friends that
are chefs that have do in-home stuff and
if they ever open something we'd be a
customer right you know so uh because
we're a customer now that kind of thing
same kind of thing with this guy and
that's a process there that you can go
through
um and pick up the book The e-myth by
Gerber and read that he talks a lot
about work learning to work on your
business not just in your business
because being a chef is one of the
pieces you have to do to operate a
successful restaurant the other pieces
are business orientation that your
husband has apparently and I would lean
into all of that I really really would
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
listening out there America we
appreciate you
if you are new to the Ramsay show and
you're trying to figure out what in the
world are we talking about dead
snowballs
baby steps what is all this work all
these words all this vernacular mean
well you can go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on the
get started button the get started
button it is a free process to help you
figure out what you're looking for in
this Ramsay journey and how we can best
serve you on this Ramsay Journey where
you are now and what your next steps are
all those kinds of things
so click get started at
ramseysolutions.com and uh we'll get you
moving and you know you become
acquainted with the baby steps and the
debt snowball and all those kinds of
things if you just keep listening the
show we'll keep we'll keep talking about
it and you'll start to understand what
we're dealing with and you'll look it up
and you'll watch a YouTube video or some
people go through if you want to do the
best thing you can do go through
Financial Peace University and that'll
line you up and get you you know get you
on the fast track to doing everything
and getting control of your money and
changing everything so all of that
to say that we're here to help you so
check it out at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America up next is
Jeff in Indianapolis hi Jeff welcome to
the Ramsey Show
well hello Dave thanks for having me on
sure what's up
hey welcome to at the risk of sounding
foolish to ask a question about 401ks uh
58 years old I got like 20K in debt
credit cards looking to see if maybe I
should make a withdrawal from my 401k
and pay them off and get going forward
on both buildings
Jeff how much do you make a year
uh approximately 100. okay
um no I wouldn't I would continue having
that money sitting in your 401k and I
would just cash flow it I mean you make
great money and this 20K you could you
could knock it out in a few months
but just with gesture with just your
income Yeah a hundred thousand minus 20
is 80. I think you could struggle
through on that for one year
yeah
uh if you take the 100 minus taxes and
all that it doesn't mean they need I
know but yeah I see where you're going
with that yeah it's not that basically
simple I mean we didn't have taxes yeah
I mean my taxes could pay for this well
absolutely good but uh so the thing is
this
um that 20 000 is going to be worth a
lot of money in that 401k in the future
if you leave it alone plus I'm pretty
sure until 59 and a half you're going to
get penalized aren't you if you take it
out
correct I just figured that would be
what you could refer to as stupid tax
yeah it won't be a 10 penalty plus your
tax rate which we have established to be
around 30 something percent at this
point and so that means you're going to
say hey I'm going to borrow money at 40
interest
to pay off my credit card that's a great
way to look at it so yeah I wouldn't do
that either and I like that money and
they're growing and I um and I love the
idea that just tighten up your budget
and let's reverse the trend that caused
the credit card debt which was
overspending and so we're going to try a
new thing called under spending and
tighten it up man and get that cut chop
up those cards have plastic surgery and
get a fresh start that's what I would do
Joshua is in Santa Fe New Mexico hey
Joshua how are you
doing well thank you guys for having me
sure what's up
um so I'm always calling just to see
what the best way to go about baby step
3B is
um I have a piece of property that I'm
tending to build a house on
um the property does have a balance on
it so I was just curious if I should be
saving in a savings account or if I
should be applying or saving towards
paying off the property first kind of
like a baby step two or what you guys
recommend and have it in there yeah well
I mean saving for for short-term savings
right now at least for the house yeah I
think
high yield savings account or a money
market accounts would be how much do you
have left on the land to pay off
uh 55 000. okay how much do you make a
year
uh I make 90. what's it worth the
property uh the property's worth 225.
okay
um you can you can build now when you
take out a construction loan they're
going to pay off the balance
and then enroll it into the construction
loan because construction loans don't
take a second mortgage position
and so if they stepped in and put a lien
on the property take out a fifty five
thousand dollar pay off the first then
that sets up to do the draws to do the
construction you're building on the
property with a contractor I assume
right
yep yes yes sir okay and currently
you've got already 150 plus thousand
dollars in equity
right yeah so you you could go ahead and
start your build whenever I I you know
and I if you want to throw some cash in
the bank to get ready to do that that's
okay but um
once you've got your contractor in place
and to put the construction loan in
place if you don't know how those work
uh they put that in place it's a first
mortgage they'll have an immediate
balance of 55 000 and then they'll draw
on it at different stages of
construction to pay the contractor as
you go along when it is completed you
will have already before you take out
the loan been approved for your
permanent mortgage and the permanent
mortgage issues what's called a takeout
letter because the takeout letter means
your the permit mortgage is going to
take out the construction loan when
you're done it rolls into becomes a a
new or re is refinanced into a permanent
mortgage that'll have encompassed
everything we're talking about the land
the house everything and when you're
done and if you're careful and you watch
what you're doing with your building
process and you you stay on budget and
on schedule and per plan don't do a
whole bunch of change orders as you go
along uh you'll keep a really good
margin in the bill itself and you'll end
up with even more equity than just the
equity in the land because the house
should be worth considerably more than
it costs to build
right okay yeah yeah
thinking to get a you know
a lower payment you know I know you guys
are saying 25 your take home so you know
I'm gonna wait another six months or so
but I was just curious if I should apply
that to the land or uh just put it in a
savings account like you said well
here's the thing I have that in six
months in six months you're just coming
out of the ground anyway
right it's gonna take you a while to get
plans finalize get a contractor lined up
and uh so yeah pile up some cash during
that time but even even then when you
just start coming out of the ground you
don't have payments on the construction
loan
okay so awesome you know you're going to
be piling up cash as you go along and so
by the time you get the construction all
completed a year from the time you break
ground maybe something like that then
you know you've got a an additional pile
of cash that you've saved during that
year that you'll put down and have a
smaller permanent mortgage but obviously
making sure your mortgage like you're
saying Joshua though by the final
permanent mortgage once it's all done is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay so
obviously the the amount of house you
build is going to play a huge factor in
this yeah so as long as you can make
that formula work 18 months from today
with the down payment plus the
construction process then that formula
then you can start working towards
everything right now take you about six
months to put all your ducks in a row
then break ground a year to build the
house that's 18 months from now is the
final balance that you end up with gonna
fit the 25 percent
and you can back into that until pretty
quick once you put your budget together
on the property we put the budget
together one of the things that's going
to happen is you're going to go oh my
God this is expensive and then you'll uh
maybe say oh I do need to wait six more
months before I break ground to make
those numbers line up at completion what
I want yeah you want you want to bring
it in at completion net of savings and
real Equity positions to where you don't
have a payment that's more than a fourth
of your take-home pay so good stuff
Michelle is in Tampa hi Michelle welcome
to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you thanks for having me on
sure what's up
and I are in a position and wanting to
know what we should do with our savings
we have
about 130 000 in cash
okay
uh where are you guys in the baby steps
Michelle do you guys have any Consumer
Debt
um we have no credit card debt we have
no car loans no student loans we do have
um two mortgages we have one residential
where we live and then we have one
investment property okay how much are
those how much is left on the on your
mortgage
on your primary home so
primary 330 000 okay and how about the
investment property
456.
it's a big investment property yeah
what's your household income
combined
okay
cool very good good for you guys well
done well what we teach is a process
called the baby steps that Rachel was
referring to the first goal is a
thousand dollars in the bank you've
obviously done that two is you have an
emergency fund of three to six months
I'm sure two is your debt free except
the house you've done that uh except for
your real estate three is uh you build
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses do you have that in addition
to the 130 or is that 130 encompassed in
that
the 130 is Encompass okay so let's pull
50 of that aside and set it call that
your emergency fund you never touched
that except for emergencies which leaves
us 80 and in that case uh that would
take us to start investing fifteen
percent of your household income into
retirement kids college so you could use
this 80 towards kids college if that's
applicable to start savings aggressive
529s and if not then we're going to
start paying down your house and I throw
the 80 at your house
and uh that's exactly what I do because
next goal is to get your house paid for
that's going to be a big building block
in your wealth building this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you're here hey if you've changed your
life with the money principles we teach
chances are it's because someone you
know lit a fire under you Mom and Dad
gave you Total Money Makeover as a gift
your pastor had Financial Peace
University at your church something
happened that got you involved well
now's your chance to share the same hope
that you've discovered with someone you
love best way to do that is the is
giving them the live and give box this
is the perfect gift for any newlywed or
graduate in your life it's everything
they need to win with money it comes
with the best thing we do Financial
Peace University and a Total Money
Makeover book my best-selling book ever
and my latest number one bestseller the
baby steps from millionaires book so
right now you get all of that for a huge
discount only 89 hey that's happening
just for a couple more days grab the
live and give box right now at
ramseysolutions.com that's
ramsesolutions.com Derek's in Kansas
City hi Derek welcome to the Ramsay show
hi everyone new listener about one week
I just graduated with my masters in
geography last week I have approximately
25 000 in student loan debt and about 7
000 in credit card debt I currently have
about a 1200 emergency fund but I also
just accepted my first job paying 35 an
hour with no benefits on a year-long
contract
I was hoping for advice on budgeting
with my new job to pay off my debt while
also making investments in retirement
and the stock market and hoping to save
money to buy my first home
great Derek I mean a lot of great goals
which we are we are our we are all for
all of that just yeah new home and uh
investing and all of it just the order
is what is really gonna matter here so
um you landed the new big job
yeah it was glad to really hold out but
um I think it was worth it so what are
you gonna be making
uh well 35 an hour so a little bit over
70 000 before tax good start after tax
Good Start what are you going to be
doing with your degree
so I do the computer side of geography
geographic information systems so GIS
yeah working for City municipality
awesome good for you that's so great
um yeah Derek so again I mean everything
you listed at the beginning of the call
are are all great goals to have and
again ones that we're fans of it's just
the the priority at which you do it is
really important and so we have found
that one of the best ways to build
wealth and to really fund a lot of those
dreams of investing and getting a house
is with your income and so eliminating
debt is is really step number one you
have twelve hundred dollars saved which
is awesome for your starter emergency
fund and I would start attacking next
the seven thousand dollars in credit
card debt and are those in multiple
cards or is it all in one
well I have two credit cards and I
recently started spending more on the
one that had a lower APR yeah
okay so you know
one thing that like we're just known for
is is getting out of debt and staying
out of debt so Derek I mean I would
recommend just go ahead and cutting up
the cards get a debit card and use your
money out of your account versus the
banks and start working your way out of
this and not starting a habit now of not
depending on living on a credit card
because there is something so powerful
about spending your own money and
knowing what's going on and if you hold
on the line Austin will pick up because
I want to give you every dollar plus
which is our budgeting app because
that's going to help you really see your
expenses and see okay here's exactly
where my money's going and that's
everything from rent to food to
Insurance to fun I mean everything that
you have in life is going to be listed
out there and you're going to really
have a a handle over when that first
paycheck hits that you're going to know
exactly where it's going and your first
Big Goal is getting out of this debt and
so it's getting out of that seven
thousand dollars credit card debt and
then your student loan and you'll work
your way down the baby steps which next
would be a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses would
be your next goal and then that's when
you start uh either saving up for a
house and for a down payment of at least
five percent uh or just going right into
baby step four which is funding
retirement 15 of your income so again
that's gonna it's gonna be a process
though this this all isn't going to
happen in the next few months you really
are going to work this and um and
starting now Derek I think is awesome so
I'm so glad you called in because the
sooner you can start building these
habits and working through the baby
steps time is on your side and the fact
that you're you're doing this now is is
huge because it's only it's only an
uphill battle from here if you don't if
you don't form these habits yeah and
don't
um the thing that's really easy to do is
get real excited uh we graduate from
college got a good job way to go
congratulations don't celebrate that by
being stupid
don't celebrate that by going and buying
a new car on payments don't celebrate
that by going and buying a house while
you still got debt coming out your ears
left over from college and left over
from credit cards let's get the mess
cleaned up because if you move in a
house and you still have Sallie Mae you
have to buy an extra bedroom just for
her
and it's just not cool don't do that so
instead let's go through the process yes
getting a house is a good thing but
buying a house at the wrong Point while
you still have debt and no savings oh
that's dumb that that's going to cause
you to have all kinds of problems so um
the point is doing a smart thing at the
wrong time turns a smart thing into a
dumb thing and so don't do that let's
lay this stuff out just exactly like
Rachel said with these baby steps and um
you know plow right through that whole
process there and to go along with the
every dollar app we'll throw in the book
The Total Money Makeover which gives you
every detail on the baby steps and why
they're in the order that they're in and
and really Rachel where those came from
is people asking questions 30 years ago
and that's how long we've been teaching
this stuff Derek um like him like okay I
got all these different things I want to
do where do I start what's the first
thing to do what's the second thing to
do just give me a plan give me a clear
path and that's why this has been so
successful and you know tens of millions
of people now have followed that process
and it it really is all based in basic
personal finance and basic uh planning
uh you know financial planning technique
a few things we nuanced and and came up
with some ideas to make it real clear
and easy to grasp and execute but the
basic concepts the framework of all of
that is nothing really new we didn't
invent it we just made it very clear
very applicable and now and talked a
whole bunch of people into doing it yeah
and that's what's hard it caused them to
get out of debt and build wealth yeah
absolutely and with Derek where he is in
life I'm like yeah you get out of school
get your first job and you're like oh my
gosh there's so many things which think
about he's even thinking about it
because some people just float through
life for a few years until they're like
oh gosh I need to save for retirement so
he's thinking about this stuff early on
in the in the process success and again
it's all good stuff I mean everything
that you said I'm like yes absolutely
we're for all of that but it's that
order and that's the thing is I think
people get scattered and you take your
income and it's like yeah we'll put some
here put some there there they're there
and they don't see a lot of traction and
progress that's why the baby steps are
so helpful is you get one at a time
check them off and you have focused
intensity especially through those baby
steps one through three that you know
what you're doing you have a goal
there's something out there that you're
reaching for and you're saying okay this
is debt my debt pay off I'm in baby step
two and everything is focused on that
and when you see progress it gives you
hope that okay I can do this and another
example of that is doing stuff in the
wrong order is what if you didn't have
an emergency fund and you got all
excited about investing you start
putting all your money in your 401k
well when you have an emergency not if
because you're going to yeah when you
have an emergency and you have no money
but your money in your 401k you know
what you're going to do cash out your
stupid 401k and you're going to get your
face smashed in with the dadgum rent I
mean the the penalties and the taxes on
the thing it's crazy what they're going
to hit you with or worse yet you're
going to borrow on your 401k to cover an
emergency because you didn't have an
emergency fund in place before you start
your 401k because baby step three is a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses baby step four is
you start investing 15 percent of your
household income into retirement there's
a reason four comes after three
because three is first hello that's how
that works and you don't need folks you
don't need to fix this it's not broken
so I need to invest I'm gonna I'm gonna
invest yeah you're gonna be broke is
what's gonna happen don't do this stuff
out of order guys it works this way
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships number one
best-selling author many times over and
co-host of the smart money Happy Hour
podcast Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality
my daughter is my co-host today open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five Nathan starts this
hour off in South Dakota hi Nathan
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Rachel thank you for taking
that call sure what's up
yeah so I'm a 22 year old farmer and I
recently in an attempt to grow my
operation bought a piece of land
um so between the land loan and an
operating loan I have about five hundred
thousand dollars in debt
so the land loan is 475 000 and it was
just a couple months ago that I bought
that
and it's just starting to set in now
um I'm going to be paying this off for
the next 30 Years and
I guess I just wanted to get your input
on what the best way to tackle that
would be
that scares me to death
does it not scare you
if yes it is
um I mean my chest is tight and I don't
owe the money
yeah wow man you're not freaked out at
all
well I am I mean
Farmland is terribly expensive and it's
always I mean I've always been taught by
my dad and
other Farmers that you just have to
start somewhere and you know start
paying some land down and
so your dad's suggestion is it 22 years
old that you go 500 000 in debt
he endorsed this plan
yes he did wow
okay
I'm not sure I'm not sure that we have
any answers for you to be honest with
you Nathan um well are you going to be
is I guess your plan is to farm the
lands and make an income off of that
correct
yes correct okay what do you anticipate
the income being yeah
well it varies a lot the farm economy
has gotten worse the past few months and
right now it's looking like
the profit from the land won't quite
make the payment so about 25 000 is like
what I think the cost will be off this
year the payment each year is 40 Grand
but on the better years it could make
its own payment possibly
yeah so you bought a business
for five hundred thousand dollars at 22
years old that loses money this year and
on a good year breaks even
well I have other land that I'm renting
from I know did you not hear what I just
said
yes that's just dumb
okay that doesn't make any sense at all
that you know if you know but because
you're a farmer you think it's okay it's
not okay
that's not that's not good math that's
not good business Farming Farming is a
business it should be a profitable
business and the way you engage in it
must be profitable you have to create a
profit and loss statement and you have
to actually create Revenue in excess of
your expenses and you put so much debt
service on yourself you can't breathe
so Nathan the extreme you know
uh decision here would be could you sell
it is there is there a
possibility are there buyers is this why
would you want to work for 30 years for
zero money
and all you do is clear a piece and he's
a second gen farmer I'm just saying the
logic of this is by your dad suggesting
this is baffling that you're going to
work for zero profit
for the next 30 Years and your net
result is you clear a piece of ground
yeah yeah it's not logical
I mean I love real estate I love farming
I love Farmers uh but but this doesn't
it's not it doesn't make sense
so something you you guys have to back
up from this a little bit and figure out
a different approach to create a
profitable business or you need to get
out of this before you get foreclosed on
right because what's going to happen is
if you borrow thirty thousand dollars to
cover your losses this year now you're
23 and you owe more on the ground than
it's worth
yes that's right and then the next year
we hope to break even
man I'm sorry I don't want to be mean to
you at all I have a tremendous respect
for how hard you work I have tremendous
respect for the fact that a small
percentage of Americans feed all of the
rest of us yes and uh but that does not
mean that because but this is not
sustainable we're not going to justify
it for you Nathan I mean like you want
to be able to sleep at night I want you
to set yourself up I want you if you
told me you're a brain surgeon and
you're breaking even I would tell you
not to be a brain surgeon you know if
you told me you were in brain surgery
believe me if I'm going to get operated
on I'd like a good brain surgeon around
if I want some food on my table I'd like
a good farmer like you out there working
man I appreciate Who You Are
and so I'm All About You winning at this
I want you to be profitable if you told
me you could make a million dollars a
year being a farmer I'd be proud for you
I'd want you to do that okay you know I
mean so this is not me hating on uh but
this idea that just but I got to tell
you man I've worked with Farmers for a
long time 30 years and a lot of them
carry on and gripe about me because I
tell them not to borrow five hundred
thousand dollars on a combine
and and then but there's this
Romanticism with farming that says oh
the math doesn't apply because I'm a
farmer well math does apply it applies
in every dad-com business and it's the
same philosophy we use for any other
business it applies if you're running a
non-profit Church serving Jesus and it
applies if you live in California you
want to buy a house right like oh it is
just the math it's the math and it's
what brings a blessing to your life and
that's our goal here and I wish I had a
magic wand mine's low on batteries that
could make this deal work I don't know
how this deal Works unless you could
tell me you can make a hundred thousand
dollars of your profit instead of losing
money the first year and maybe the
second year and maybe the third year and
ending up owing a hundred thousand
dollars more within a couple of years on
this property than it's worth
and uh that's not a plan so would you
say sell it that'll rework the business
model I mean if they're I I don't know
how he what he's doing I don't know what
his crop rotation is I don't know what
his particular crop choice is I I don't
know you know what he's looking at why
why you're going into a business that at
22 that you're planting that you're
planning to lose money well it could be
the CR I mean it could be the weather I
mean that's another thing about the farm
economy and the farm economy depending
on which segment we're talking about is
struggling yeah I don't argue that point
either but you can't just you know you
can't open a restaurant and lose money
yeah the first year in the second year
and oh so much that you can't pay your
payments that's why that doesn't it
doesn't work in any business and man I
wish I could make this better for you I
but you've got to either rework your
business approach to this or you need to
look at getting this sold before you get
yourself bankrupted by your dad's
horrible advice this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Cruise Ramsey personality is my co-host
today hey let's clear something up if
you listen to the show for 10 seconds
you'll know we hate that
and some people for some reason don't
get that they think you need debt you
need credit cards to build your credit
well we think you need a good credit and
because they think you need a good
credit score to buy a house well you
don't the truth is living a debt-free
lifestyle eventually you won't have any
credit score if you don't have any open
accounts and you don't use credit at all
eventually your credit score will
disappear and when you're ready to buy a
house you got to find a good lender like
Churchill Mortgage who can do what's
called manual underwriting
like George Campbell when he and Whitney
bought their first home which is now
paid off they got it through Churchill
Mortgage at a zero credit score and they
got the same interest rate as a premium
credit score would get
you are not penalized if you have a
mortgage company like Churchill that
knows what they're doing might sound
crazy but the best plan for your future
is to avoid debt get a big down payment
get a great real estate agent who will
help you find a house you can actually
afford we recommend our endorsed local
provider agents they are Ramsey trusted
that means they're a top performer in
your Market there they are high octane
high protein if you're going to sell a
house get with somebody sells a bunch of
houses not somebody who got their
license last week who happens to be your
friend from college that's dumb
don't do that this is your house okay
get somebody that actually knows what
they're doing that has a proven track
record in the area go to
ramsaysolutions.com agent you can find
these Ramsey trust agents do you
remember well it was probably two years
ago now that people were starting to
talk about the bubble the bubble the
housing bubble is gonna it's gonna it's
gonna burst it's gonna burst it's gonna
be another 07 you know like the oh yeah
the freak out and then we did the big
the the reality the real estate reality
check
live stream and so you know the market
we've said it saw I mean it's cooled
down it's not as insane as it was thank
God uh yep so we're stabilizing and so
uh on Instagram I know you love
Instagram reels uh a guy a guy had a
whole thing about how the number one
market that's gonna burst very soon is
Nashville and how Nashville it's gonna
for all this stuff and then I went and
read through the comments and they were
like are you insane like have you been
to Nashville and seen the econ because
it's it's still crazy in Nashville right
I mean like there's still there are
still fewer houses more guys still
saying that yes there's a guy that and I
just saw it the other week and I was
like oh no not Nashville because we we
experience it here and it's like people
are still flocking and still moving here
uh but what we can't get you to not come
I know so for you and your perspective
with real estate specifically like what
what trends are you seeing
out there because I mean I kind of just
I I see Nashville know Nashville but
overall the landscape the the bubble has
not burst
we are still okay but it has it has
softened right some I mean it's not as
it's not as urgent and freaked out as it
was but overall what are you what are
you saying I think
um
you know I think we can just stop and
say I told you so can't we I mean
because we did like 18 months ago when
everybody was frantic because the market
had slowed down and interest rates were
coming up
we did a two hour long
live stream I would imagine you could
still watch it and go back and watch it
and I think you'll see in that
that we predicted exactly what has
happened
now now we don't always get it right but
we were using data not emotions to
actually figure out what's going on and
the data was this there even though the
interest rates have gone up there still
is a dramatic inventory shortage in real
estate in almost every city
in order for prices of anything to come
down
Supply demand curves have to shift
meaning that the supply has to be much
higher than the demand
but when there is the opposite a
shortage
versus a glut in the market when there's
a shortage prices go up
so if you want to cause the prices on
something to go up make it scarce
make it make it be a shortage there is
not a shortage of real estate there is a
I mean there is a shortage of real
estate and so the the opposite of prices
tanking everybody's oh it's all going to
go away it's all going to be right 2000
and we kept saying no it's not it's not
going to bust it's not going to bust it
we said it is going to slow down yeah
and we said if you're going to sell a
house you're going to have to actually
clean it up
and Stage it which is you know and you
can expect on the market again you can
put it on the market you expect 90 to
120 days and you can expect not to get
110 percent of your asking price with 87
offers on one weekend that was an
anomaly that was a short period of time
after covid when everybody sat around in
their house got fat and decided they
wanted to move out of their house
and no one was building anything because
materials there was no there was a
shortage of lumber Lumber went up 3x
it's back down uh and Builders are
Builders are not building specs right
now yeah they slowed down and they're
adding to this shortage because the it
slowed down and they don't they don't
get stuck with a spec house and so spec
house starts our way off which is
hurting the inventory even more you
can't find a house in a lot of markets
so you have not seen prices crash you've
seen them steadily increase we said in
the year 2023 you were going to see a
two to a seven percent increase in
prices Nationwide and that is about what
we're going to see and that's what your
home is actually valued not the inflated
price that people are throwing out there
yeah right these people could put an
extra half a million dollars something
insane on you know and people would just
buy it this is not asking price this is
actual value that's right that's right
actual value and it's not people buying
like they've lost their dadgum mines
this is people reasonable people buying
properties at reasonable prices you're
going to see that number you know you
put a house on the market for three
hundred thousand dollars expect to get a
an offer you know of 280 and that you're
going to negotiate yeah and expect to
sit there for 90 to 120 days to sell the
house and expect that if your house is
ugly and dirty it's not going to sell
so that's not unusual that's like 90 of
the years that we've had real estate
operating in America it's been that way
we had a short period of time when it
was cray-cray and we covered all of that
in detail and then it has happened
exactly the way we said yeah so no
whatever
characters on whatever Instagram
economists that's like it was funny
though it's like an oxymoron I'll be
honest not that I fall for everything I
see on the internet even though
that sometimes is the case
yeah not everything but motion I had a
moment where I was like oh gosh what
does he see that I'm not see I don't
know and then you know I'm watching it
again I'm like that just doesn't feel
right and the funniest part is just
going to the comments because people
just ripping everyone's like I'm a real
estate agent National are you kidding me
like smoking something yeah so anyways
it was it was good but that's what
you're saying that's just good to know I
think that it's good to kind of just get
a pulse on
um and then interest rates obviously are
they're up they're up and do you ever
see them coming back down to that to
three percent I don't know I I don't
know what interest rates are going to do
I will tell you this you can have a
healthy sustained realist residential
real estate market for home buyers and
six percent will just rock it for days I
mean we've rocked it for decades at six
percent the only reason it was driven
down below six yeah was artificially by
the government driving it down to
re-stimulate the real estate market
after 2008. but prior to 2008 for uh
what 15 years it sat around six yeah you
know when I came on the air in uh
1992 doing this show the rates were like
nine
and we were selling lots of people
selling houses everywhere nobody thought
anything about it yeah and then they
came down to six and we thought oh this
is awesome this is great because six is
great when you're comparing it to nine
six is not great when you're comparing
it to two and a half yep yep you know
and so it's it's all your point of
reference the secret to happiness is low
expectations right so
oh my gosh but yeah that the you're
you're right we should have stopped and
said I told you so because we don't know
what I was asking no I I you will take
this moment no we really should do that
every so often because we get so much
stupid hate mail by people on these uh
social media channels and everything
else that we don't know what we're
talking about and we completely nailed
that yeah I mean our team here and I the
Ramsey personalities looked at the data
and we said this is what's going to
happen and we hammered it we nailed it
and it certainly wasn't the crash of the
real estate market that a lot out of you
or believing and predicting was going to
occur 18 months ago
just think back to 18 months ago and
that's about when we did that live
stream so go look it up this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today welcome to the Ramsey Show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Carrie is with us
in Montgomery Alabama hi Carrie welcome
to the Ramsey Show
[Music]
what's up
um so I recently got a divorce well I
left him last summer it was like a
domestic violence situation that I had
to get out and I was in nursing school
full-time and so I got out and I got
back on my feet like a lot quicker than
I thought I would um good for you a lot
quicker than he told you you would
oh yeah he said I'd be nothing you know
and you're gonna you're gonna be you're
gonna be the rock star that we all know
you to be I'm proud of you
yeah and um but anyways he kind of
controlled the finances so I did um have
I had a credit card left but I hadn't
been using it I kind of used it to get a
lawyer and to kind of get back on my
feet and so I had about six thousand
dollars left I had like 16 but I was
contained it off
um and then I got a job I work in like
medical sales now and on my base paid
like 60 and with commission I make on
top of that
um about five to seven every month it
kind of varies my worst month was like 3
000 but it was when I was getting
started
um but I did buy a house in November
unfortunately when interest rates were
7.25 it's an FHA loan I have 26 000 auto
loan on but a three percent interest
rate I got a really good interest rate
on that and then I have about 18 000 in
student loans so I'm just wondering like
what I should pay off first and then we
just closed on our house we flipped
houses together and I we had to split
the last profits uh 25 000 from that
that I just put it on the market I got
it I got it like a week ago that'll jump
start your plan yeah good it's making
it's like a 4.5 apy so it's a really
good money market it's so funny no
um
should I keep it there what do I
pay off first I really want to get a
better home interest rate but I'm just
not sure when I'll be able to do that
you know yeah well Carrie you're you're
doing an incredible job I mean you
absolutely have
um taken hold of your life I mean you're
doing incredible work wise you're making
great money and yeah you're just in an
incredible spot which I'm really I'm
really happy for you and I mean that's a
courageous
um the whole event isn't a courageous
thing that you just stepped out of and
you said I'm I'm taking life back in my
own hands so I'm just really I'm
impressed by you in that way
um do you have any other money saved
besides this twenty five thousand
dollars that's in a money market account
um not really like I have my banking
account set up for um like 20 I just
stuck it up to 40 of like when I get
paid it just automatically goes to my
savings my money market
um so I was saving like 20 each paycheck
so I have about 2 000 then savings on
top of that so maybe twenty seven
thousand okay total that's great okay so
what I would do is I would take this
twenty five thousand dollars and we
teach you to pay off the smallest debt
first so with that 25 000 plus you have
two thousand dollars in your set your
other savings which I would take that
down I would drain it down to a thousand
uh so you really have twenty six
thousand dollars that can be thrown at
this debt which means you can pay off
this credit card
and then you'll be paying off gosh this
this auto loans you only have six
thousand dollars left on your car no by
the end of today no you got twenty six
thousand and eighteen and twenty six on
the car right
she has six thousand dollars in credit
card debt no yes four thousand of that
is like a 24 month interest-free credit
card you got an eighteen thousand dollar
student loan
yes
so you got 18 000 student loans how much
on your credit cards
um six thousand but four thousand of
that is like interest-free I don't care
we're not going to play interest free
games and interest rates don't matter
you are in debt we need to clean up the
debt okay when you get the debt cleaned
up you're gonna have no payments
anywhere in your life and you're making
money you're going to put this whole
horrible mess in your rear view mirror
and it's just going to be smoke back
there it's gonna be awesome I love it
okay so I would write a check today and
pay off your credit cards and I would
close every one of those credit card
accounts and use only a debit card for
your transactions then I would pay off
the student loan today
okay and then you've only got the car
left at 26 000 right
yes okay
people people who's talking about the
student loan forgiveness do you think
that's ever going to happen or
no
okay and you know what even if it even
if it does you borrowed the money you
owe it
yes sir okay and you make good money now
you're gonna be making a hundred
thousand dollars a share aren't you
yes sir yeah so pay off your 26 000
student loan
okay who cares yeah and the house I
bought is a fixer-upper so should I just
wait on fixing up the house yep okay yep
let's get the debts cleaned up because
when you don't have any payments but the
house payment you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year you feel that
freedom already when I just said that
mm-hmm wow
you got no payments but a house payment
you can fix that house up pretty quick
yeah and no more debt
no more debt you don't need any banks
telling you what to do you got rid of a
jerk that used to tell you what to do we
don't need anybody else telling you what
to do you are amazing go get it done
girl
yeah and when should I refinance my
house since I just bought it when you're
able to get a lower interest rate
all right as soon as you call Churchill
Mortgage and find out what you've got to
do is your credit damaged by this mess
is that the problem
um it was like a 650 but now it's back
up above a 700. when did you do that but
before before after you got the seven
and a quarter
um I did that a couple
when I first I got like 32 000 and I
paid most of it off with that and then I
was making chunks of I was doing like a
thousand dollars payments on the credit
card go ahead and get rid of this debt
all this debt and when you get rid of
all this debt you're gonna see that card
that score jump up again and right when
it does that if you can get down around
a six percent that'll give you a one and
a quarter savings that'll make it worth
refinancing and call Churchill Mortgage
and get that if you can get it down to
six percent or lower it's going to be
worth refinancing
and should I do a 15 year or 30 years
always a 15-year
and Hey listen you're asking a bazillion
different questions about all of the
different things because now you're in
control of your life again and I want we
want to help you with this recovery this
bounce back that you're doing and give
you the confidence on the money piece to
do everything I want you to go through
Financial Peace University because we
want to be a little part of your amazing
story and so you hang on we're going to
have Austin pick up we're going to pay
for you to go through this class it's
online you can do it
and you're is you know when you get all
these answers these questions are all
swimming around your head and you're
going to go through this class and go oh
now I know exactly what to do your
confidence is even going to soar more
and you're probably going to make more
than 100 then you'll probably make 100
and a quarter and with that care you're
going to get every dollar plus as well
and so honestly too the the amount of
control you're going to feel of just
budgeting when that paycheck hits
knowing exactly where it's going and
once this debts paid off because even at
the end of today I'm like you could have
just your car loan left at 24 000 and
not get out so you can actually start to
see your goals and where your money's
going and being really intentional with
it and there's something empowering too
about that and again especially from
what you've walked through the last year
and a half to be able to have full
control over that income where your
money doesn't even have you like you
truly have it you are the one
controlling it there's something in that
too and just that simple budgeting app
I'm telling you that's going to give you
so much freedom and so much confidence
so we're excited for you Carrie by the
way for those of you out there that
think you have a friend or a relative
that is a victim of uh domestic violence
married to a jerk who thinks his wife's
a punching bag
let me tell you a real symptom the data
shows this and we know this from 30
years of working in these situations if
the guy is one thousand percent in
control of the money and will not let
his wife make a single decision of any
kind with the money there's a high
correlation between that behavior and
domestic violence
because if he can control the money he
thinks he can control her and this this
whole domestic violence thing is about
control
and so if you see a guy who's doing that
to his wife he's probably beating her
that's what I'm saying not a hundred
percent but there's a high correlation
of that this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you're here hey if you're liking
the show thank you
and uh we know that a bunch of you are
spreading the word on this show because
our rankings and our ratings continue to
go up and that means there's a whole
bunch of new folk out there thank you
thank you for joining us and help us
spread the word there's a couple things
you can do to push the needle on this
whole process if you're a YouTube viewer
or listener obviously you can subscribe
and you can share hit the share button
and same thing with your podcast you can
subscribe you can share over on Spotify
or Apple or Google Play wherever you are
we're Everywhere by the way we're on
every stinking platform that is
imaginable
SiriusXM yeah 680 talk radio stations
yup number two talk radio show in
America in terms of number of stations
and number of listeners
Undisputed not even close on the second
Sean Hannity is number one and uh where
we are honored to be in a number two
slot so hey thank you guys for that tell
people about the show maybe you're
watching on TBN tell people you're about
to show don't share them share share
share share share subscribe subscribe
follow and if enough if the format
allows you to leave us a five-star
review if you want to leave a one star
review just change the channel okay
people get mad when you say this because
they go and do one stars and they're
like because they told me not to do this
I'm going to do it so really yes
just don't mention the one Stars just
say if you here I'll do it I'll show you
I'll show you I'll show you okay I'll
show you all right show me how to do it
so if you guys love the show if you find
that it's really helpful and encouraging
make sure to leave us a review we really
enjoyed we love reading them and and
hearing I don't know
Lord have mercy I tried James I really
did I tried you need to go read your
reviews because it is helpful I'm not
taking a poll we're doing the show
if you guys love it thank you we
appreciate you and we'd like to read
that you do and it helps the algorithm
there's a lot of reasons for them when
you leave a five star it doesn't when
you leave a one star when you're trying
to destroy the show go over to Smart
money happy hour because we read your
reviews there for sure yeah George and I
love them they're inside jokes so do an
inside joke of a review right now Dave
like like everyone leave the like
Emoji or something and then you go
through and read like oh look there they
all are oh yeah it's fun interact with
the people Dave come on I do dad I do a
talk radio show for three hours a day
five days a week that's interacting with
the people right there that's when I do
that yeah oh my gosh just a review it
does help
them every day so James James
reads them for me that's what it is I
used to not I knew see I but you should
the way I care is I have James
I'll tell you the shames you need to
tell him to stop saying not to leave one
to us I knew that if I told him he would
double down and that's what he's doing
it's not working at all and
true how are you
I'm doing good I think I'm with Rachel
on this one I think you might have
activated the internet trolls
I know right Andrew tell him tell him to
stop oh such a boomer way to go man way
to go thanks Andrew you're no help at
all next caller
we're here for you Andrew we're here for
you how can we help you brother
so uh my wife and I just bought a house
in Orlando Florida we're moving down
from Louisville Kentucky
um and we're having a bunch of uh home
repairs pop up and you know we plan for
these repair like some repairs pop up
but kind of the numbers getting ahead of
what we budgeted and kind of want to get
your take on how we can handle it
like what
so uh we knew that it needed a new roof
um it probably needed new Plumbing
um
so we so we uh we had like 25 Grand set
aside for that
um we're toward the end of that and now
we still have our six month
um emergency fund
um so right now there's a hole in our
kitchen floor down to the crawl space a
couple joists are bad
um
and that's sort of where we're sitting
right now
how how what happened to the hole how
was there a hole notice there was all in
your floor
well uh no uh so on our last trip we
started ripping up the floor uh so we
knew something was bad in there so I
started ripping it up and then the
subfloor was rotted so it ripped that up
and then Joyce below it were
uh were bad too that's a fine piece of
property isn't it
Yoshi had the price down from you know
20 20 grand
um
but it cost you 25 Grand to get to the
point that you just have a hole in the
floor
right but we got it below uh what it's
worth
not if you only negotiated it down 20
grand and the repairs were 40.
yeah that makes sense yeah so okay so
here we go so how you gonna fix the
floor
uh we're planning on doing the floors
ourselves
um What's it gonna cost
uh we're I mean we're probably thinking
a couple grand for that uh but then
after that you know we'll have
countertops uh cabinets to put back up
um so our plan was just to
just get the floors down and then cash
flow until probably Christmas to where
we can get the money together to get all
the kitchen done how do you operate your
household without a kitchen
toaster oven in a mini fridge
um
your wife is a champ
man you gotta you got you got a deal and
you got her camping wow oh man
um I don't know what else to do though
you're here
how much you guys make a year Andrew
160. we're expecting to make 160 this
year okay so yeah that's great and cash
flow pretty quick with that great income
that's the good news in the story okay
yeah yeah let's get the floor done and
get moved in and because y'all moved
from to move from Kentucky to Orlando
uh we got jobs out here we're opening up
a engineering office down here so okay
part of the official crew okay
for work okay
good good well yeah I think you got your
plan I mean you got a cash flow it and I
don't want you down to uh you know
not having a kitchen is pretty close to
an emergency but I don't know you could
just decide if that's an emergency or
not you could take some money out of
that yeah he already is you press the
floor
so would you recommend just going down
to three months for now or just yeah
yeah
I want to get this kitchen done and just
have a habitable property I mean toaster
oven is quasi-habitable right
right yeah when you're at the toaster
oven level that's a pretty different
level so toaster ovens are great yeah I
know but that's the only thing there the
sink doesn't work yeah the whole thing
yeah so just yeah yeah wow and um yeah
and then the rest of it you know any
other improvements you're going to do
you have to get your emergency phone in
place and then cash flow above that once
you get the kitchen once you get the
kitchen thing in the rear view mirror
how old are you guys Andrew
I'm 26 and my wife's 22. how long you
all been married
about two years now any kids
no kids okay
I'll look at this I'll give you I'll
give you a warning okay you probably
have made all of the withdrawals on home
repairs in your marriage that you'll be
able to do I doubt she's going to do
this one with you again you probably got
your One play here for the rest of your
life I played my cards well yeah this is
the I think you completely made all the
withdrawals on that part of the bank
that you can I'm guessing that this girl
this young lady is going to say uh-uh
not again or she may love it she may
love the adventure she might she might
yeah but I'm guessing
um this is the kind of stuff your mom
would have gone along with with me when
she was 22 but the chances of her doing
it when she's 62 really close to me
leaving before this happens okay so
a toaster oven the toaster the great
what was that the little blue the
toaster it was like an old Disney
cartoon
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author co-host of the smart
money Happy Hour podcast on the Ramsey
networks and my daughter is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Esther is
with us in Dallas hi Esther welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um I am calling because
um my husband and I have a few questions
and we don't know which way to head we
started um Financial Peace University at
the beginning of last year and
everything was going great and we paid
about 50 000 in debt so far way to go um
thank you because of some of the things
that were happening with our school
district and whatnot I was a teacher I
decided to quit my job and homeschool my
kiddos starting last summer and
um obviously that put a little bit of a
dent in our debt snowball however my
husband had received an increase which
was making up for my loss of pay and
everything kind of went okay we were
able to make ends meet
um well recently my husband's company
the cut pay from everybody in their
company and that's going to be about
over 20 loss of income for us going into
next month
so it's putting us in a difficult
position it would make things a little
harder what did your husband used to
make
um he was making his take-home pay was
right under a hundred thousand they gave
him a twenty thousand dollar pay cut
50 uh 20 percent about 20 of 100 is 20
000.
right yes
yes and what does he do
sting
um
architectural type drafting
okay
well the economy in Dallas is booming
why is this architectural firm cutting
pay for people
that's that's our question as well it's
not they didn't say why
no no and he might be temporarily
have something to do with it look for a
job
yeah why are you staying in a place cut
your pay twenty percent
in a booming economy
that's what we're looking at yeah um
today
yeah yeah it's not a theory I mean yeah
he's that that's disrespect he just got
disrespected
yes they were waving a flag in front of
him to leave
and it's everybody in the company I know
it's not just I know but yeah it's not
they fully anticipate several people
leaving as a result of this cutting
their payroll costs down this is
anticipated this is a strategic move on
their part
they're telegraphing this to you saying
leave and I would oblige
yeah go get a job making 120. if I'm
Healed and I bet he can do it by Friday
if you get on it
yes I think you can okay um
yes so one of those in our on our to-do
list for it this week
we did everything stupid that we could
do with our money we were comfortable
and we had the life fell supposedly to
match it which was just in our minds not
reality however since we started our
debt snowball like I said things were
rolling along however right now we are
getting a little bit frustrated that we
are
kind of like stuck on the same place for
a long time when you quit your job and
your husband got a 20 pay cut of course
things are tight
yes they are um and my question to you
was
should we even consider selling our
house to no you need to get your incomes
back up
what's your house payment
um about 2 400 a month it's it's very
good compared to what's going on right
now yeah
so you may be tutoring and subbing while
he gets his income up to 120.
and then the house is not a problem
anymore the house only became a problem
when your incomes went away
yeah am I right house is not even our
biggest issue it's paying everything
else down
well you've already gotten rid of fifty
thousand dollars worth of debt back when
both of you had your incomes
yes
so you can sub how much do you have left
Esther in debt
a lot
how much
80 about 200 no about 200 feet on what
student loans we have a personal loan we
had a HELOC
um
a car loan
yeah
okay how much are student loans
um mine is about 30 000 and my husband
is about twenty thousand right on their
20. okay so 50 in student loans and so
how big is the HELOC
about 80. okay and that is
um
in addition to your twenty four hundred
dollar payment
yes okay you may have a house you can't
afford then yeah
because when you put the payment to
those payments all together on your home
you've now got house payments that are
really getting very high even with your
old incomes
yeah it's about 2 800 which is still
less than what we would be paying in
this breaking in Texas but yeah what do
you uh well no that's not true I mean
it's less than you pay for that house in
Texas but there are cheaper houses in
Dallas
right the um uh so how much do you owe
on your cars
[Music]
the two of them were at 41
. okay give me a breakdown on that
which cars how much
my car is about 31.
600 and my husband it would be the
difference I'm sorry I don't have it in
front of me right now that's okay yeah
so here you know the way I look at all
this stuff is what I would do if I woke
up in your shoes Okay number one the 20
pay cut activates me looking for a job
immediately and it activates you doing
something for income you've got a
teaching certificate you can sub you can
put you can do some while you homeschool
you can still pull it when it's summer
right now technically so yeah
tutoring absolutely great great money
tutoring really great money tutoring and
I'd pick up a bunch of that and get his
income back up get yours up temporarily
I'd sell the thirty one thousand dollar
car in about 20 seconds
I wouldn't keep it but before I sold my
house I would be cleaning off a whole
bunch of this other stuff
and I would be willing to paint lean
into this because selling a house is
expensive
it's expensive to move it's expensive
emotionally uh it's expensive everything
and if you can if the house can be
solved if you can work your way through
this and get rid of these debts and get
your incomes up temporarily for a period
of time to plow on through this then
you're there but if you decide to quit
your job you may have decided to sell
your house you for sure decided to sell
your car
you maybe didn't mean to but those
decisions all came together because of
the math
they they were they were knitted
together you couldn't get rid of them
they're tied to each other so
that's the deal I'd sell your car and
I'd get better jobs immediately and
really by Friday you can do that and all
of a sudden the situation starts to move
around give yourself a little breathing
room and then you can decide later on
the house this is the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our question of the day comes from
neighborly yeah the Ramsey Show
questions they sponsored by neighborly
your hub for Home Services take your
home's efficiency and style to the next
level with convenient solutions from
shelf Genie window Genie glass doctor
and dryer vent wizard visit
neighborly.com to schedule home service
professionals near you all right today's
question comes from Michael in Illinois
my question is about continuing to pay
for our 19 year old son's insurance
deductible he lives at home and pays 400
rent each month he is not in school he
works full-time and plays video games
wage is 25 an hour he's on our health
insurance plan which doesn't cost any
extra my wife thinks we should pay his
deductible I feel like it's time that he
takes on the responsibility of being an
adult
how should I handle the situation your
wife his wife thinks we should pay the
deductible he said yeah yeah
um
well he works full time
I just think that's funny and he plays
video games why is that funny I don't
know because I'm like
it would be sounds like a teenager well
you could be like well he works
full-time and watches Netflix at night I
don't know like it's just like a thing
you do I don't know why video games is
like the thing that he tells us about
because it pisses his father off I think
so
exactly why yeah he looks satisfied
because he's useless yeah uh nobody but
he works no I know his dad just doesn't
like it I know I mean I don't know
Michael I I mean he's paying rent I
think he should move out
um yeah but if it but I but I mean what
it was with the whole Obama Care
situation that it bumped up to 25 right
that you can put on your parents health
insurance okay you can you could
disagree with me this that doesn't
bother me a part of me is like yeah if
you until he moves out he's on his own
he goes and gets a job that has benefits
maybe that's what he needs to be doing
um but if he's 19 I mean he may have
just graduated high school and
he's figuring it out I don't know I
don't think the deductible is the issue
your problem Michael yeah I think your
problem Michael is you think this kid
needs to move on yes and instead of
saying that you want him to pay the
deductible right so the deductible's the
symptom the question is the symptom of
the whole situation so here's what I
think will solve your angst Michael on
the video games in the deductible both
okay
is if you put a schedule on when he's
leaving
and so I would sit down with him and say
I'm your dad I love you and I I'm here
to help you
and I'm not here to uh support you for
the rest of your life and so you're
doing a good job earning some money
I don't really need a renter
so I don't need your rent money uh what
is best for you as my son is for you to
stand on your own two feet and have the
Dignity of operating your own household
and I want us to work up a plan that
moves you towards that so this
indefinite sitting here playing video
games while you could be out doing some
extra work to get on with your life or
taking a class of some kind uh trade
school certificate whatever it is
um instead of getting a degree in Mario
Kart you know or something so
um yeah I mean it's not being productive
this is me and this is me as your dad
Loving You Well saying we're going to
develop a plan for you to be on your own
and if you want to live on 25 an hour
and
um work only 40 hours and not uh engage
your brain and grow your mind and grow
yourself in a self-growth mode
um you're gonna struggle my son so I
want you to think about that I want you
to think about what you're engaging in
and
um so when is it that you're planning to
exit when do you think is a good plan to
exit it doesn't to be in two weeks it
doesn't even have to be in two months
yeah I don't care if it's six months but
if you say a date certain okay that um
you know after Christmas
you know you're going to have found a
place and be in it or whatever the
number is that we all come up with and
and then I'll help you get there I'll
help you with your budget I'll show you
how you can get extra work doing other
stuff and
um you know if you want to consider what
your career field is going to be and for
the time being I'm like if he does this
job and then a side hustle at night and
he doesn't have benefits would you be
mad if he stays on his parents insurance
no yeah I don't care if he stays on the
insurance the insurance is not the
problem yeah the problem is the sense
that he's uh lazy
child yeah in a young man's body yeah
that's what's bothering his dad and his
dad just didn't know how to say it but
that that's and it's not good for the
young man right right totally good for
him to have a a plan and I I'll just
tell you moms or does if your 19 year
old doesn't want to go to college I
understand that and I'm okay with that
but no post
School post high school learning is a
plan to really struggle through your
whole life
so everyone should study something
um I I read three non-fiction books in
the past 30 days and I'm 62.
so I mean really everyone should study
something all the time and if I can do
it he can do it you should always be
learning something knowing something
doing something you didn't know before
so that you have a better life and uh so
be you know I don't care if he wants to
become a welder if he wants to become a
diesel mechanic I don't care if he wants
to be a coat go to code school and have
a path have something you're working
towards do something you're learning and
doing Beyond uh I'm Gonna Make You know
basically the minimal entry rates and
try to survive on that it's going to be
tough it's going to have a tough life so
I want to help him with that I want to
help him extend his career Direction and
I I uh and I want to help him get on his
own because when he feels the pressure
of actually doing his own thing yeah out
there in the real world it change it
it'll change his emotional maturity and
uh you know I heard something the other
day that uh in France one of the
parenting philosophies that they have
apparently I don't know this is true but
I thought it was good uh is frustration
they want their kids to feel frustrated
so there's not kids menus when you go
over to France I mean they really do
make the child adapt into adult adult
yeah because they're like and you're
gonna feel frustrated about that but you
need to because when you feel frustrated
you're uncomfortable you have to make
decisions you have to understand problem
solve right where in America we're more
just like we want to make you
comfortable and we we don't if you feel
frustrated we'll fix it for you right
it's that helicopter type parenting you
know we want to create an environment
where you have no stress yeah so even at
19 it's like yeah have a little
frustration in there and have to kind of
figure it out a little stress in there
yeah and again this is not an act of uh
being mean or something like that or
being angry but I can tell you this
Michael is a dad all right of grown
people
um the frustration you have is not with
video games
you would not mind him playing video
games at all if he was studying and
working towards a goal in his career if
he was standing on his own and he was
and he was making more money and he was
working overtime and he was paying his
own bills that's what made me laugh yeah
but that's where that the frustration
yeah it comes out there yeah the video
games you're not frustrated with video
games you're frustrated with all these
other things and you're because he could
be doing those things while he's doing
the video game so that's what's
bothering you yeah and it's also an
indication of emotional immaturity at
this stage of the game so um that that
that that comes up in this discussion
yes not everybody plays video games is
emotionally immature it's not what I'm
saying but that comes up in this
discussion as an indication he's afraid
his son is not yes maturing yes and uh
that he's still thinking like a 16 year
old right right that doesn't work when
you're 19 and it sure is cred doesn't
work when you're 29. so that's a good
that's a good question
um
yeah this uh Failure to Launch thing
it's very real yep it's very real and
moms and dads the numbers are
astronomical
the number of Millennials and the number
of gen Z's that moms and dads are paying
their bills is crazy the average is
1425 a month
that you guys are paying for your
and I love this phrase your grown kids
what is a grown kid
I don't understand what that is but yeah
it's an oxymoron I think but yeah for
your children who have grown up but they
didn't and so you're paying their bills
you're paying for their house payment
you're paying for this you're paying for
that you are not helping them
you are not helping them you are not
giving them the dignity the freedom of
agency they're they're feedback loops
are not closing you're not creating
emotionally mature people wow
and the devastating effects on This
Nation are amazing to go with that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey show we go all out for our
listeners
we're going to give away some money the
giveaway is ending soon though hurry and
enter for your chance to win the big one
the three thousand dollar grand prize
with the Ramsay cash giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
increase your chances of winning by
entering daily no purchase necessary got
to be 18 or older to win
ramseysolutions.com giveaway just a
couple of days left on this if you want
to get in our books are all on sale for
ten dollars each
all of our number one best sellers all
of Rachel's number one bestsellers all
of my number one best sellers deloney's
Coleman's they're all on sale ten
dollars each and I got to tell you with
inflation our costs on these books have
gone up dramatically what it costs us to
produce a book and I'm not completely
100 sure this is the last ten dollar
sale but it might very well be because
I'm pretty sure I'm going to go up on
those prices I don't think we're going
to do any more ten dollar sales because
the stinking cost has just gone through
the roof on these things so if you want
these books at ten dollars this is the
time to get it done as fast as you
possibly can go to ramseysolutions.com
you want to load up on books at ten
dollars might be advisable Gabriel is
with us in Washington D.C hey Gabriel
how are you
good how are you doing it's Gabrielle I
messed up I'm sorry how can I help hi so
I recently just got a job making a
hundred thousand dollars and I'm trying
to make a plan to go back to my PhD
program after after working and saving
for a little bit of time my programs are
fully funded but you only get about
twenty eight thousand dollars a year so
and I don't have any other debt right
now so I was just wondering how much how
long would you work for and how much
would you try to save up in order to
accommodate that kind of like salary
reduction in the future
I'm confused
you're gonna go get a PhD you make over
a hundred thousand dollars a year you're
going to go get a PhD and what do you
mean by fully funded
you get paid a salary to go do research
so you'd work for the school while
you're getting your PhD exactly oh you
would quit this job you would quit this
job and go work yeah and you would make
how much while you're working for the
school
33 000. so you would take a seventy five
thousand dollar pay cut
yes
in the research and in order to get
further further and career this
after I worked for a couple of years and
how long does that take
okay so this is a 250 000 expense
because you're gonna lose 75 000 a year
for four years
yes
I'm sorry it's a 300 000 expense and the
end goal though Gabrielle is is that
you'll have your PhD is this the and you
want to what will you be doing after
those four years
government research working in labs and
going towards managerial roles in Labs
making what kind of money doing that
you can make up to 200 000 in my in my
field specifically doing those kinds of
things okay
and so you're willing to invest 300 000
of lost income into this process
okay
do you have a family are you married
kids nope okay okay so what what expense
do you have can you live on the 33 while
you're doing it
yes
okay so what do you what do you need to
save for then they're going to pay for
the PHD right
they will but I want sure that I have
I don't want to lose these kind of best
years to invest my money for retirement
and because during that time it's a
little bit harder to make that kind to
make a big change to your retirement in
accounts while you're only say well
you're only bringing in that much money
oh yeah you won't have any money yeah
you'll be barely making it you're going
back to college yeah for four years
you're going to college so during
college you're not going to be doing a
bunch of big investing how old are you
free good for you well you're you're
very smart
so I think this is the time to do it I'm
like if this is the if this is the track
you want if that you obviously know what
you want
um yeah I mean I would when are you
thinking realistically that you're gonna
go next August like a year from now yeah
within the next one to two years okay
yeah that's great oh you know it
um I would practice living on thirty
three thousand and banking the rest of
it while you wait
that sounds good and I would go sooner
rather than later
as soon as you can get into a program
that sounds good yeah and because you
want this behind you as soon as possible
so that the 200 000 income is in front
of you as soon as possible yeah and I
wouldn't be worried about the investing
side Gabrielle I mean obviously compound
interest is awesome but you're so young
that I'm like and you're gonna be making
great money when you come out of this
program so even if you started investing
at 28 years old you're going to be okay
and we're let me make sure I'm very
clear because I want to make this is a
type of a fellowship in a sense that
you're an employee of the of the uh
school and so you are having no cost so
there's no student loans involved in
this process
okay all right that's what I thought I
understood but I wanted to make sure
what I was agreeing to that's great well
congratulations Gabrielle that's really
a lot of people call into this show for
Masters or PhD or law degrees I mean
they come in and and usually the answer
is like or they they think the answer is
like well I I the only way I can do it
is student loans so the fact that even
you're finding a program like this and
you're obviously extremely intelligent
to work in the fields you work in and
it's great I think that's really
exciting and at 23. yeah it's very
impressive very impressive yeah well
done do it do it do it do it have fun
yeah that's going to be great but I
would go as soon as I could yeah
um there's you know piling up money in
an investment account somewhere to get
ready to do this that you don't have to
have to do this is not a necessity uh so
I would start as quickly as you can get
as soon as quickly as you can get this
lined up with someone again you've got
to live on what they pay you when you're
doing it
um to the extent you can't do that you
do have to have some money piled up to
subsidize your years but if you can live
on the 33 they're paying 33 and
everything else is covered ding ding get
after it I love it I love it Well Done
Graham is in Boston hi Graham welcome to
the Ramsay show
hello Dave Rachel how do you feel I'm
calling because I'm married in October
and my in-laws they're gifting us some
property and they're okay with us
selling it but they want us to develop
it first and we don't even have the
money for our own you know house you
know down payment we're working on that
right now but how do we approach this
and do in a way that's respectful
towards them
well it's a gift with strings attached
because they're why do they want you to
develop it
uh they're fine with us selling it but I
guess they want us to I don't know put
into the community or something or just
try to get more out of the uh just get
more in the final sale yeah
well you're brand new newlyweds how old
are y'all
um we're 30. okay do you have a bunch of
money
certainly not okay
so you don't need to be developing real
estate
yes we know that and we're friends that
we want to sell it but they're that's
just what they're saying so yeah I would
just say I would just tell them I don't
want it then I don't want it
you can keep it
if it comes with me having to develop it
and I don't have the money to develop it
I don't want it
it's a burden it's not a gift
these people are weird
that's a control freak move man well
they're probably thinking I know they're
trying to be nice but they're they're
completely interfering yes you can't
give someone a gift with that many
strings attached that's right it's
controlling totally totally it's not a
gift it's not a blessing Graham I mean
because you can't do anything with it
you got to sit there and pay taxes on it
right
yes sir yeah so do you want it Graham
uh I would like the sandwich for the
down payment the one certainly would
help us get into a house faster yeah and
again we're trying to you know tell them
look we don't have the money to do this
and uh I mean we like the you know the
down payment money but if you require
that we develop it before we sell it
we're going to have to turn the gift
down because we're not able to develop
it and thank you we appreciate it it's
very kind of you to offer this but it
doesn't fit with our plan so uh since
you're if you require that we develop it
before we sell it then thank you but we
won't we can't accept it because we
can't do that and so it doesn't fit with
our plan but thank you it was very kind
it's a nice offer and just walk away it
was an offer not a gift that's a great
waste this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today Deuteronomy 31 6 be
strong and courageous do not be afraid
or terrified because of them
for the Lord your God goes with you he
will never leave you nor forsake you
do not stop thinking of life as an
adventure Eleanor Roosevelt said you
have no security unless you can live
bravely excitingly imaginatively unless
you can choose a challenge instead of
competence
wow pretty cool
good stuff open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host Steve is in New York City hi
Steve welcome to the Ramsay show
yes good afternoon sir good afternoon
Rachel uh long time listener Dave I was
hoping to call you
and ask for a get free scream but I had
a kind of I kind of pulled put a pause
on it I came into some money due to um
and it's a final estate
from my mom so I was hoping to just take
the money pay off the mortgage but now I
have uh children that are going to be
getting
um College next year and everyone's
telling me kind of put the brakes on
kind of just trying to decide where to
use this money where it doesn't hurt me
that I have a paid off home and that's
why uh you you and me who are the first
ones to come to mind to kind of maybe
help me through the situation it doesn't
hurt you if you had a paid off home are
you talking about benefits for college
Aid or something
right well I don't well I don't say like
having a paid off home is going to
uh you know in terms of what you can get
in financial aid if they look at it as a
you know it's a positive for you but oh
you know you don't need as much Aid
because you have a paid off home
uh well they don't give Aid there is no
College Aid programs except for people
who are poor and you're not poor
there's no grants are you talking about
like scholarships and stuff
I'm sorry there are not need-based
scholarships for people who have the the
income that you have and the assets that
you have
so the the need-based scholarships are
based on people that don't have any
money
and you guys well that's I'm saying I'm
just
you go to these universities you know
they work with you and all you know but
they look at all your financials you
have to fill out the fast faster I know
and now and none of them give financial
aid based on in based on uh
need what's called need-based financial
aid to people who have substantial
assets like you do
and and a good and a good paying job
like you do so there's not Pell Grants
are show up for somebody who's at the
poverty level is what I'm saying and the
financial aid at individual schools are
it's all need based and you're not going
to qualify for any of it anyway
okay and you don't want to you don't
want to put yourself in a position to
qualify for that if you don't have to I
mean like if you got a single mom that's
making 20 grand and her kids going to
school she can get financial aid okay
that kid can get financial aid but
that's not you Steve and always Steve
too that scholarships and grants I mean
they're not all needed it's not all need
based either you can get you can get
scholarship and they're not all academic
and they're not all there's scholarships
and grants for a little bit of
everything
uh I mean they're Scholars maybe maybe
that's what I'm getting could be so
maybe what I meant like in terms of
scholarships also
having a paid off house if you've got
two million dollars if your net worth is
two million dollars and everything's
paid for and you have a big old polit
cash in your bank it doesn't keep her
from getting a scholarship that she got
based on trumpet or whatever based on
based on the fact that she is a a you
know uh you know wrote an essay and
she's a good citizen okay because that
that you can get a scholarship for that
but they're not they don't look and go
oh you have to be financially pitiful to
get these scholarships that's that's not
what the case is so no do the right
thing for your finances now the right
thing might be to not pay off your house
and you make because you may need some
money to pay for your kids calling
right that might be the right thing but
but paying off your daughter
uh 17. okay she's getting ready to go
have you picked out of school has she
picked out of school y'all picked on
school no no she'll she'll start next or
August of 24.
okay but you're so you're shopping for
schools
and you're looking for yeah and so the
thing I want you guys to do is to start
studying scholarships and there's lots
and lots and lots of scholarships that
are not academic they're not need based
and they're not Athletics so you don't
have to get an athletic scholarship you
don't have to get you have to be a 4.2
uh valedictorian and I and you don't
have to be a single mom making twenty
thousand you you know you don't have to
be any of those things there's lots and
lots of scholarships out there that are
just five thousand dollar two thousand
dollar fifteen hundred dollar
scholarships and if your daughter
applies for a whole bunch of those and
then you guys decide to pick a choose a
school that you can afford
where she doesn't have student loans
with the money that you've got from
other savings and from this inheritance
then
you're going to be you're going to be in
um
you know really that that's the way to
get at this so here's what we're going
to do I'm going to send you a copy of
our book Debt free degree
which will help you guys walk through
this and because most of avoiding
student loans is is picking a school
that's affordable School choices school
choice that's the number one math
problem in going to school debt free uh
and then number two and three are work
while you're in school and apply for
like a hundred scholarships like a
bazillion scholarships and uh work it
that way that's what I would do so yeah
but paying off your house
um does not keep you from getting those
types of scholarships if the if you have
the money to do that and get your kid
through school so good question Jesse is
in Cummings Georgia hi Jesse welcome to
the Ramsey Show
sure
of your home school property taxes keep
increasing
um I already do a dollar for dollar we
have no debt except for our house and a
little bit of car debt that I plan to
have paid off in the next three months
um we go dollar for Dollar on our budget
after taxes and insurance and all the
other costs we have a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars in our base
take-home pay and our school budget
keeps um doubling every year and I'm not
exaggerating four years ago it was 300
million dollars and now it's 600 million
dollars and all that comes onto the
property owners for our School portion
of property tax
so how do you work with your current
budget that you have when they don't
hold their own budget but you love your
school system and you know can't help
that your house is now double what they
say it is but you're not moving
uh you include your increase you include
your increased cost
for taxes
in your monthly budget
and if you don't want to do that you
move
do you ever at some point hold them up
like figure out how to hold the like I
guess this system accountable for what
they keep doing to the people that they
supposedly serve I guess that's the
problem that I'm having I think that
would just be called getting politically
involved and uh removing some of these
school board members that keep passing
as onerous budgets but that's uh that
doesn't affect you that's not a
budgeting technique that's just I'm
pissed off you people keep spending my
money
yeah it's a political fight because
you've got school board members that
don't have an off button I had a pug dog
that didn't have an off button it kept
getting fat because it would eat
everything in sight sounds like these
people are kind of the same
yeah it seems like they don't know how
to use your
yeah I don't know is not one of their
words and so it's a word they need to
learn and uh politicians everywhere this
you know Universal as long as man has
been alive that when you can spend other
people's money it's uh it's always easy
to do
now if it's helping teachers be paid
more I am for that so knowing what
you're spent what they're spending I
don't think the teacher's pay got
doubled no that's what I'm saying that
I'm like 300 million to 600 million I
doubt they doubled their teachers pay
yep which is sad I doubt it I doubt it I
doubt it that's just somebody doing some
kind of other
stuff there that's going on and also you
pay for it I mean we're in a nice County
and our kids go to public school and
it's an amazing school but you you pay
for it you put the property tax but this
is not free yeah
yeah look what the government gave me
for free nope never happened that puts
us out of the Ramsay show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]